[Music]
so Kanye West is now officially a
billionaire office of homeless clothes I
read about millionaire what'd you read
you know when a millionaire a
billionaire there's like two ways of
looking at it there's the one where you
obviously you have a million dollars we
have a billion dollars right and then
you're a millionaire billionaire and
also there's like the net worth one he's
that net worth one so what they did was
you know like big he's trash they did
the traditional like appraisal method
where they took how much is easy brand
is worth and how much it makes every
year
and they have like you don't you sell a
company it's usually like a multiple of
how much you make that year depending on
the industry standard ah yeah so
sometimes like the multiplier is like
four or five six seven eight nine ten
right here's I guess when they appraised
his the conservative own number was ten
times so they said it's somewhere
between like 1.3 to 1.6 billion but he
thinks he's worth 3 billion ah I don't
like that y'all oughta do the numbers
where he loves Trump that's exactly what
Trump would say they don't like Trump
via their down well it's funny because
this Forbes article they're pretty much
saying like yeah so Kanye was crying
about the fact that we didn't call my
millionaire last time we interviewed him
last summer and so are you gonna be a
dick you literally said in the 40 years
that Forbes has been around and been
doing this [ __ ] there has only been
three people that quite about being I'll
leave been told yeah he's a Saudi prince
he cried about it well cuz he is a
billionaire Donald Trump cried about it
he is a billionaire
Kanye West has cried about it prince2
also Auto Prince not the musician Prince
know that was the full name of that
there's a comment the prince the crazy
part is if I was a billionaire
I'd be telling all the press you know
like I wanna like yeah I put a target on
your head I know because you're not the
entry-level billionaire like these guys
you're [ __ ] you're thinking like the
top-level billionaire like the Koch
brothers or Putin yeah I don't get
fascinated I don't have the time no but
you want everyone to know you and you
want everyone to to think that you're
the [ __ ] but now they're gonna pay for
every time we go out there good thing
all births gonna get the bill yeah he's
a billionaire who cares
it's all an ego thing cuz they for Kanye
though he's just like he actually
publicly complained he said I showed
them speaking about Forbes I showed them
an eight hundred and ninety million
dollar receipt and they still didn't say
billionaire stop keep disrespecting him
dude yeah he literally said it was a
disrespectful article G and that they
were purposely snubbing him I bet you of
Kanye West said hey call me ma'am they
would but they won't call him a
billionaire that's so [ __ ] mean yeah
it's just funny because uh right here
they're just pretty much saying like you
know they broke down like how they they
calculated his worth and all that and
like Bart said it's mainly like net
worth type of thing like properties or
whatever assets what's the breakdown um
so they're saying like for example I
think cash was like 18 billion dollars
I'm having 218 million he has a
billionaire so he has 18 million just
liquid just liquid and then I think he
has wow like 80 million in property Wow
and then like maybe like improperly in
real estate
yeah and then like another like 80
million or something like that in stocks
do you imagine being at dinner with
Kanye and then you expect him to pay
horses Rich's [ __ ] yeah there and
then he's like oh hey like just so you
guys know like I'm mostly tied up in
assets
[Laughter]
the bill comes on like yeah I forgot my
wallet guys is that is it cab awesome we
gonna have something cards up yeah I'll
buy you guys dinner um oh and you think
about a hundred mil and I think maybe a
hundred million yeah 100 million and and
debt is what he has 100 million debt
it is so he has 3.8 million under
vehicle way it's a club it's gonna sound
weird on the microphone everything
mm-hmm
you know sitting on there earlier I was
like I wonder if they can hear it so he
has three million in vehicles alone 3.8
for vehicles 297,000 for livestock's
cows just animals I guess so they're
saying that documents that they reviewed
for West's GOOD label and his own
recorded music and publishing rights to
be worth at least 90 mil oh yeah cuz he
owns a music label that like most def is
under common is under all those guys run
oh man that sucks most def is under is
probably not doing that good huh yeah
all the artsy like so famous
that's worth 90 million 90 million yeah
about and then there's something they're
talking about he has to 14 million
dollar ranches which is nearly ten
thousand acres and he has animals like
so you're telling me on the part time
he's cowboy it's a good investment dude
you'd be surprised he's driving a herd
that means wearing his manga hell he's
doing that which makes sense this guy
needs the vlogs like I see what his life
is like me too so interesting man like
what birthday he has 81 million in
buildings and improvements 21 million in
land I'll just empty land I guess yeah
it was meant to be his his little
civilization your son oh those grass
huts who's gonna get homes almost people
do you get in like Malibu here yeah yeah
to build like a place a haven for people
or something like that yeah any luck
with his own religion kind of thing or
no he was just teaching Christianity you
think I think so yeah it's not kinda ism
I don't think so but I think he'll get
there the funny thing is people think
money changed this man and I'm like he's
always been a [ __ ] egomaniac it's just
that he seemed nuts until he got super
super rich and then now he's like
eccentric yeah he probably had $50 in
life stock before and now it's just
$200,000 of my stuff he always had life
stuff like Dave Chappelle stories of
Kanye before Kanye was Kanye I tell you
what type of human this person is
I'm Kanye West and I do dope [ __ ] yeah
who the [ __ ] says that Oh God yes Oh doh
why are we so self-aware son I feel like
the more the bigger your ego is the more
you can accomplish in life I mean look
at all the big driving force that's for
sure the greatest dictators of the world
they would call themselves geniuses too
and they're not even trolling because
they're very utilizing their ego
correctly because there's another
version of that where you have a
gigantic ego and you're just so like
bottom of the barrel like not successful
like you there's too stubborn everyone
away from you
yeah too stubborn like you're too into
your own [ __ ] head so what does a
healthy egomaniac look like Kanye West
probably Kim jong-il I don't know
healthy well why don't you want a huge
copper statue of you and your dad and
your grandpa all together in an area
where thousands of people are there to
weep for you every year I would have my
grandpa's statue of him holding Jin on
the rocks and it'd be a fountain oh
that's good and flick their coins in and
make wishes on your yeah yeah and that
would be so awesome because all a day of
your name and people come to your grave
every year to visit so millions of
people kim il-song was his grandfather
and everyone has to know that you know
it's crazy there's a picture of his dad
Kim jong-il in every single hospital so
after they get surgery or anything they
look at him and they go thank you you're
you you saved my life
don't they have to have their picture in
their heads - yeah right there like a
living Saint yeah isn't it crazy that
that otto warmbier kid was like brain
dead and in North Korea and then now Kim
Jong Un's brain-dead kinda or like any
Co he might be possibly just dead dead
yeah hope you dead that's kind of scary
ironic it's because he's fat cuz he
loves Hennessy and he's drinking a lot
and eating a lot and people told them
yeah that he means chill out because he
has high cholesterol and blood pressure
but he's like shut up boo oh my god I
heard Hennessy kills the corona virus oh
[ __ ] I forgot what who was it the
president which country Vietnam he sent
out no he sent a bunch of Hennessy to
two people in the city because he said
that Hennessy kills the corona virus and
you throw in an interview and he has he
sent out bottles that's great it was
people our country is actually pretty
good to be honest I mean our president
is telling you want to inject the
[ __ ] disinfectant yeah but he's not
sending us as disinfectant
I really need our cast ecclesia I can't
get this infected anywhere wait try told
people to inject themselves now so he
was at a press thing I think yesterday
and there was a medical professional
there and then he like looks overheard
he's like you know can people just start
people can just disinfect themselves
right what if we inject disinfectants it
kills it that works right yeah
yeah he's like I want doctors to do it
and they could do like a cleaning where
you they inject it inside of it and this
chicks like they're like please don't
inject I had to tweet that the best [ __ ]
is when stick to hotels but is when
you're dot you're you are working for
somebody and they say something nuts and
you can't like a moat that much so it's
just like yeah you're like I thought
you're so blindsided that you don't know
how to deal with the answer whenever
Trump's talking there should always be a
guy next to the video camera cord just
ready just this
god damn sure yeah what he said he was
being sarcastic so I think we could take
it I think we took his word but think
about it there's complete dumbasses out
there that are billionaires - and
millionaires of course what's there to
tell people what's the common
denominator the ones that they were born
in for it yeah but it takes mm-hmm it's
difficult to keep it it's like winning
the lotto right you got to understand
how to maintain that - that's why I'm
saying bro nobody is that good like
everyone doesn't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing so that's why I think
anyone can win so what separates us from
them well connections I guess yeah money
skills yeah drive like they're they're
taught differently than what I think
Gandhi was I think maybe Kanye just had
like some a bunch of people around who
doubted him enough where he's like [ __ ]
every single one of you I will literally
own all of you and he actually did it I
think that that happens to where it's
not just like people always say like
like rocky people yeah exactly
maybe that's all he wants to be known as
a billionaire - just so he knows that if
he's known publicly then he literally
owns everyone now when it picks up
newspaper like oh [ __ ] Kanye's a billion
and I doubted him dude look at the
statistics on asian asian people you
guys are more likely to own your own
businesses and to be richer than most
people and you know a lot and then a lot
of it at the same time people always say
like oh i wish i had to dope parents who
loved me so much and I'm like dude I
don't know if that works every time I
think it's a lot of people over
sometimes I think yes I think sometimes
that person like Eminem has talked about
this where he's like dude I didn't have
a situation where pants and that's what
drove me like the hardest is cuz I
wanted to prove myself to literally
everybody cuz I could prove myself to
nobody at home my friends a
multi-millionaire because his dad
gambled away all the money and he had to
make money for the family that sucks man
see that put that there you go it's
driving it's a conflict that is driving
and we have JK because of me embark on
beat the [ __ ] up as kids and we we had
to figure out a way to laugh about it
yeah everyone needs some sort of
conflict drill so you're gonna start
creating their own that's true I'm
friendly to everyone in the world except
for my parents yep
[Laughter]
[Music]